Hello!
How much do you want?
Then, what's your final price? Okay?
I'll give you 20.
Pretty impossible!
Why are you so stingy?
What's your last price?
I'll give you 20.
A little bit more.
Are you wanting to kill me?
For just the price of 25.
Okay, I'll take the money.
Why are you very cheap?
Welcome to the Silk Market.
Ten percent of the asking cost, usually.
If you go to one place and you give them a price and it's too low,...
...you just go to the next because there's definitely stores that, they all have the same thing.
Just keep going lower.
Sometimes, you got to play them against each other.
So if it's too low, you just go to the next. Raise your price by five kwai and start over.
Stand your ground.
Start extremely low and always tell them to give you a better price, and always walk away.
And if they don't like it, then you just go to the next.
And you can just keep going and going.
Walking away is the key to winning any victory.
I want to make friends with you.
Don't look around, don't walk around.
I'll sell to you at this price, okay?
How much?
For this shirt?
Yes. That's good quality.
You can machine-wash it and your wife can handwash it also.
For how much do you want to buy it?
I don't even want this shirt.
But if you want it, how much?
Don't joke with me, okay?
Are you feverish?
I think you feel very hot.
If you give me that, I'll give you that, an even worse number.
Are you okay?
Yeah, are you okay too?
Just a little bit more.
Just a little bit more, a little bit.
Are you being fair with me?
That would cut my work cut from here!
You're a hard sell.
What's your maximum?
You already gave me the last final price and it was way too much.
Okay, this can be your last price.
What's your last price?
Final, final.
Okay, 70.
No.
75?
Okay, give me your money.